okay okay hey welcome everybody to the
third day of the beyond the Buddha Cube
Workshop so our first Speaker today is
nimanari and he's going to talk about
discrete sampling via continuous random
work so take it away all right thank you
though thank you for the invitation uh
happy to be here
um so yeah so the title of this talk is
as you can see parallel discrete
sampling via continuous box this is a
joint work with Gidget yeah new Jun uh
Brian and Catherine and June uh
um yeah so if the title seems vague to
you this is the title that seems easier
to remember dolly for spotting trees
so let me explain a little bit
um so the goal of this talk is to
introduce some sampling algorithms and
actually the algorithm is based on the
thing that Dolly uses to generate images
everybody here knows about Dolly right
so these are uh these like uh dolly is a
model by open AI that you type in some
like text it generates an image for you
and the process it uses to generate that
image is a sampling process uh so very
cartoonistically it starts with some
Pure Noise and uh it's uh it's over many
many steps it denoises it to something
that looks like a you know good image
okay
and this process is actually very well
known in the theory Community by another
name called stochastic localization so
these are formerly the two same
processes
um so the goal of this talk is uh but
you know in in the theory Community this
has been mostly used in as an analysis
tool whereas in diffusion models you use
it as an algorithm to sample
so the goal of this uh talk is to give
you some new algorithmic applications of
stochastic localization
all right so let me give you like a
brief primer on uh sampling so the
sampling Community actually people
usually divide themselves based on
whether they work on continuous sampling
or discrete sampling uh so in the
continuous world you have some
Distribution on our end you want to
sample from it here there is really like
one good tractable class similar to how
in optimization like there is one good
tractable class convex functions in the
continuous world uh uh distributions
whose density is log concave log of the
density is concave is the tractable
class
so it's slightly even better uh similar
to like uh you know well conditioned
convexity you can also have
well-conditioned lock concavity this is
when uh it's not only true that the
Hessian of the log mu is negative
semi-definite but its eigenvalues are
sandwiched between some beta and Alpha
with beta or Alpha boundaries
so when you have this condition you
don't have to even think about like a
clever algorithm very standard
algorithms similar to like uh gradient
descent for optimization but here uh a
noisy version of that work
okay
I think it's fair to say that in the
discrete World things are not as like uh
you know as as well defined uh so in the
description let's say you have a
distribution and a hypercube you want to
sample from
um there is really a patchwork of
incomparable conditions under which you
can sum
so one of these uh uh one of these uh
tools that allow you to sample in the
discrete world is sampling by accounting
so what do I mean by that so there are
some problems some very specific
problems for which you have some sort of
accounting Oracle so what do I mean uh
you have a hypercube you have a
distribution on the hypercube you have
an oracle that given the description of
a subpiper cube uh it it gives you the
the the mass on that subtitle okay so
that's that's what I mean by counting
for the stock
and here are some distributions for
which we have this good Oracle
um so let me go through them so spanning
trees is uh is perhaps the most famous
one uh so in the spanning tree case uh
we are the distribution you want to
sample from is given a graph you want to
sample uniformly random spanning tree
and we view this as on the hypercube
let's say n is the number of edges and
plus one indicates presence of the edge
in the spanning tree minus one indicates
uh non-presence
and your Mew is putting a mass of zero
on the on the subsets of edges that are
not a spanning tree and a massive one on
the subsets that are that are a spanning
tree so if you wanted to compute the
mass of the entire hypercube for example
you would be able you would be needing
to count the total number of spanning
trees and this is doable via the Matrix
330. you can write it as a the as the
determinant of some laplacian Matrix
um similar thing works for the sub Piper
cubes so in the subpiper cubes uh you
condition on some edges being in or out
but uh similar thing holds
so another famous case is player perfect
matchings here your distribution is
given a planar graph you want to sample
a uniform you're on the perfect matching
again uh due to a famous theorem uh fkt
you can again write this as the
determinant of some Matrix that's easily
computable
another example that's maybe like less
familiar uh is eulerian tours uh so here
uh the distribution is you're given a
directed eulerian graph and it has one
eulerian tour but it could have many so
your goal is to sample one uniformly at
random uh so uh because of some theorem
that has the best name ever uh you can
again count this uh so this your this
best theorem allows you to write the
number of eulerian Tours in such a graph
as the number of arborist senses time
something and the number of
arboristencies again you can write as a
detail
uh so this last one is a little bit more
complicated to describe let me just
describe it uh briefly but don't worry
if you forget it
um so here uh this is a determinantial
point process it's described by some n
by n Matrix and uh uh it's uh this n by
n Matrix gives you a distribution on
subsets of one through n where the
measure of a subset is proportional to
the corresponding principle minor okay
so the determinant of the principle
minor
uh you need obviously these principal
miners to be non-negative for this to be
a distribution so this happens in two
very useful cases one of them is when
this Matrix is PSD
another case is when this Matrix Matrix
is skew symmetric so in both cases you
get non-negative determinants and this
gives you a distribution so those are
two flavors of the terminal point
processes
and again if you want to let's say
compute the measure of the entire
hypercube you can just simply do it by
Computing the determinant of your Matrix
plus I you can just expand this out to
see that this is a determinant the sum
of all the principle minors
so when you have this useful counting
Oracle you can easily translate that to
a sampling algorithm this is the easy
side of a well-known uh
equivalence between counting and
sampling due to German value and time as
Irani and this is really the easy side
because I'm going to show you what it
looks like on a half of the next slide
so imagine you want to sample a standing
tree you have a counting Oracle here is
what you do you go over the edges one
byte one by one and for each edges you
just compute the marginal of it
conditioned on what you've done in the
past
and once you compute the margin of the
first Edge you flip a coin with that
marginal and decide whether you to keep
it or not and then you just condition on
what you've done and you compute the
next marginal and so on so each of these
probabilities is just the ratio of the
measure of two subhypercubes
it means
the problem with this uh the problem
with the sampling algorithm that it's uh
is that it's very sequential
so uh here I need to know what I've done
in the past to know what probability to
compute right
uh on the other hand for all of the
problems I showed you on the previous
slide because the count can be reduced
to a determinant computation we have
very fast parallel algorithms for them
so here the notion of parallelism I'm
using is uh this notion and C uh you
have Palm so think of it as you have
power nearly many processors into the
100 processors and your goal is to
reduce the time to polygonics okay
so uh shanky basically showed that
anything you do in linear algebra can be
paralyzed uh including Computing
determinants uh so uh you know so this
raises the question of uh we have good
algorithms to compute these marginals
can we somehow make this process more
parallel so that we get parallel
sampling on this
so uh yeah so the goal is to sample in
parallel so we want RNC type algorithms
the r just stands for randomized because
we have to use randomization in sampling
and the main result I want to show you
is that yes in most of the examples I
showed you except for this planar
perfect matching case we can do this by
going beyond the Boolean hypercube uh
uh so yeah so so interestingly
um uh we we had an earlier work where we
tried to really stick to the Boolean
hypercube and it seems impossible to
just uh make it work but uh if you if
you move beyond the Boolean hypercube to
continue space to to our end uh you can
actually make these algorithms fast
all right so here is the outline of the
rest of the talk uh I want to tell you
what's the connection between discrete
and continuous first uh without telling
you the algorithm and then I'll tell you
what the algorithm books
uh yeah so the connection itself is very
self-maintained uh very cute
um so there is there is really like not
a lot of things that you can do to to uh
to go from the hypercube to to RN one of
those things is taking convolutions or
making the hypercube uh or convolving
with noise
so that's the thing we are gonna do so
uh so we have this distribution on the
hypercube I'm just gonna convolve it
with the gaussian so add independent
caution noise to to my samples
and here I've drawn the picture of uh
three different convolutions with
increasing width of the gaussian
as you can see uh you know my
distribution here is like very jaggedy
and then suddenly here I get a very nice
unimodal distribution it has it no
longer has like two modes and stuff
so so this is really like the main
Workhorse Workhorse of our work uh we
showed it for all of those distributions
except for your perfect matchings uh if
you come involve with gaussians after
the variance of your gaussian passes a
certain constant threshold you actually
get very nice distributions in fact log
concave distributions the kind that were
easy for the continuous sample uh
so yeah so uh so this is true for uh
this is true for spanning trees for uh
uh for eulerian tours uh for uh for dpps
but not true for planar perfect matches
so I want to show you that actually this
level is very simple
it has a two-line proof here
um
if you think about uh if you think about
what this Commonwealth distribution is
I've just written the PDF of this
convolved distribution here at a point W
uh you just sum up the contribution of a
gaussian center that each X
so this this part is coming from the
gaussian this part is coming from new
and notice that if I if I open up this
quadratic uh
uh so so W Squared term uh actually goes
away because uh sorry the W Squared term
you can Factor it out the x squared term
is constant for everything in the
hypercube and then you get this term
which depends on uh which depends on wnx
it's the inner product of wmx okay
so uh so so so one thing to note is that
these sampling algorithms that we have
for in The Continuous case they need
some sort of access to your distribution
the sort of minimal access that they
need to your distribution is for you to
be able to tell what the PDF at a
particular point is or up to
proportionality what the PDF at a
particular point is and I claim that for
all of the all of the discrete uh uh uh
distributions new that I showed you
before uh we can actually give you this
PDF
so if uh if let's say you wanted to
compute this PDF at the point let's say
w equals zero right
um this part is easily computable
um this part uh when w is zero is just
the sum of mu X over the entire
hypercube that's exactly the counting
algorithm that I have right
when w is not zero this I claim is a
weighted version of your problem so uh
so for example in the spanning spanning
tree case e to the WC is giving you some
positive weights on the edges of your
graph and the weight of a spanning tree
is the product of the weights on the
edges and here you're just Computing the
weighted sum of these finities and all
of those determinant based counting
algorithms actually work on their
weights
all right so so one one good observation
here is that you actually do have access
to the PDF of this continuous
distribution
uh but you can also see this fact from
this simple calculation if you take the
log of this expression and then take the
Hessian of this there are two terms one
is coming from this so minus I over C
plus this part requires a little bit of
computation but this is actually a
standard function this is called the
Laplace transform of your mu and the and
the Hessian of log of this is very well
studied very well known it's just the
covariance of your distribution
I've written it at the point w equals
zero but the same is similar things hold
at other points
so from this calculation you can see
that as I increase C the width of my
gaussian
um at some point this first term which
is negative is going to win over the
second term which is positive
and basically all you need for this
thing to become negative semi-definite
is that your covariance is not too large
so the Hessian of this thing is PSD the
Hessian of this thing is negative
semi-definite there are these two like
opposing factors and uh yeah so I so
that's why there is a specific threshold
after which this thing becomes
okay
all right cool so uh so so there is a
threshold uh like uh determined by the
maximum eigenvalue of your covariance
Matrix after which this thing becomes
lock concave and if you go slightly
below above that threshold let's say
that threshold of c0 but you go to two c
zero you not only get lock on cavity you
actually get well conditioned locked on
cavity because this really wins over the
second term
what are the entries of this covariance
Matrix yeah so the covariance Matrix is
simply this uh uh it's the expectation
of like XX transpose minus expectation
of expectation of X transpose where all
these expectations are taken when X is
sample from mu
so it's an N by ending
cool
so uh all right so now I have to tell
you so I I cheated a little bit I just
completed this Hessian at the point w
equals zero uh you could ask what
happens at other points uh so let me
show you what happens at other points
very quickly
so at other points you have to deal with
weighted versions of your distribution
that's all uh so uh remember this was
like a weighted version of our
distribution so this is uh what I'm
going to call in this talk exponential
tilt sometimes people call it an
external field
uh when you basically uh multiply by uh
by something that's log uh log linear
um so basically uh e to the w dot X
that's how that's a factor that you
multiply by your distribution
um that's another Distribution on the
hypercube uh you can think of it as
weighted spanning trees if span
increases the thing that you remember
so yeah so so this is an operation that
Maps distributions to distributions so
the spanning trees become weighted
spanning greens uh dpps actually become
dpps with rows and Columns of the Matrix
defining them just scaled
um
I'm surprised nobody asked this but
eulerian tools are actually not a
distribution on the hypercube
uh so I'll tell you what happens in the
old area and tourist case later
um you have to first somehow make it a
distribution on the hypercube and then
you'll see uh what happens
uh but the moral of the story is that
the class of distributions we are
dealing with they all are the are uh you
know somehow connected to determinants
they are all closed under uh this sort
of exponential tilt uh so everything is
good okay
so uh at any point W uh the convolution
before that I showed you before would be
negative semi-definite as long as uh The
covariance Matrix of these exponential
tilts are bounded so at w equals zero
you need to you needed the covariance of
your original distribution but at other
points you just need exponential tilts
of Industries
okay
so this condition uh surprisingly has
been studied before uh this condition is
called semi-lock concavity in a work of
Eldon and Shamir although they didn't
observe that this corresponds to really
low concavity of convolution with
cautions
um
okay uh so the the reason we know this
condition holds for all of the
distributions I showed you is that we
actually know something even stronger
for them so there is this framework uh
spectral Independence that has been very
useful for sampling problems in the
recent years and spectral Independence
really uh uh is is basically equivalent
to this condition that I wrote here so
instead of the covariance of your Matrix
being bounded by some multiple of the
identity it's bounded by some multiple
of its own diagonal
um yeah people if you're familiar with
let's say I don't know High dimensional
expanders or spectral Independence this
is really like spectral Independence at
the link of the empty set just written
in the language of covariances and
things that probably understand
um yeah so so the diagonal of this
covariance Matrix has bounded entries uh
so this is a distribution on the
hypercube so the diagonals of the
covariance are always at most one
because they're just variants of a
Boolean random a
this is always smaller than this
and everything except linear perfect
matchings has this property
now let me take an interlude and tell
you what happens to eulerian tours
so uh okay so to to go from uh to to
make eulerian tours uh uh uh workable in
this framework uh we have to first map
it to the hypercube so that we can then
map it to beyond the hypercube
um so to do that I have to introduce
switching networks uh if you were here
for Ryan stocks
uh uh on Monday the uh uh you might you
might uh you might first see some
similarity but this is really not uh
what I'm going to talk about Ryan talked
about like these baby distributions and
baby squares and so on uh what I'm going
to talk about is really like the giant
versions of these babies
okay
so all right so so eulerian tours how do
we represents them on the hypercube
so uh here is the trick you you can
actually reduce uh general or illyrian
graph to one in which the in degrees and
out degrees at every vertex are two and
to do this you need a switching Network
gadgets so here is what this gadgets
look like let's say we have a vertex of
degree three I'm going to replace it by
such a gadget uh there are three
incoming lines that corresponding to the
three incoming edges and three outgoing
lines and you just put uh these like
switches in the middle each time
connecting two wires and the way you
think of it is uh you know a random
switch is happening at these uh things
uh and then once you once you determine
a switching Network that gives you a a
distribution on permutations yeah
so the goal of this gadget is for the
permutation and the output to actually
be close to uniform on the space of all
permutations so Ryan talked about like
ways of generating uh random
permutations that have closed like low
moments but here we really want like
everything to be close
um all right
but once you do this switching Network
gadgets now you have a binary Choice per
vertex uh because the in degree and out
degree are two there are only two ways
to map the incoming edges and to to the
outgoing edges like this and this
um so you so now your distribution is uh
like really on plus one minus one to the
end call one of these plus one call one
of them minus one
um and some subset of plus one minus one
to the N gives you eulerian two or some
subset gives you like disconnected
Cycles
so uh but even after you do all of these
reductions pushay showed that there is a
there is a determinental way to to to
write the count of these weather in
terms this is actually separate from
this is different from the best theorem
that I mentioned in the beginning
showed that there existers use symmetric
Matrix L such that its principal miners
basically tell you whether uh some
particular set of switches give you an
Euler unit or not so all of its
principle miners are zero or one and you
get one exactly for ethereum two or zero
for it for
people who are familiar with the jargon
uh this is actually like a Delta nitrate
so so okay so after you've translated
everything to the hypercube now it makes
sense to talk about exponential tilts so
exponential tilts become biased
switching networks so instead of instead
of these switches happening with
probability one half one half they just
happen with probability P one minus B
where p and 1 minus B uh they are like
they are like tangent hyperbolic of like
these weights
okay so how do you construct these
switching networks let me just uh
briefly mention it uh as you might guess
like uh random switching networks
actually work
uh so if you have a degree many incoming
wires and degree many outgoing wires
just construct a random one each time
pick two wires put a switch between them
and if you do this for roughly like
degree log degree money uh your outputs
are close enough to uh being uniformly
random
but because we we are able to deal with
bias permutations you don't even have to
deal with uh you don't even have to deal
with like approximately uniform uh
permutations uh there are networks you
can construct with biases up size
degrees squared that give you exactly
uniform permutations
let me also mention this as a fun like
Side open problem
if you want to get exactly uniform
permutations as far as I've researched
it's open what is the minimum size you
can get here so just by entropy bonds
you can't go below like degree log
degree but uh but degree squared is the
best we know
cool so so once you once you replace
everything by switching networks you get
a distribution on the hyperactive and
you are in the good graces of our
framework
um all right so let me summarize this
part
um
so I started with telling you that we
have some sort of counting Oracle uh uh
that Maps uh hyper sub hypercubes to
measure to the entire measure on that
subpiper Cube and then I I pulled the
rug and switch this counting Oracle with
a more sophisticated one that gives you
really like the Laplace transform of
your distribution but the observation
was that for the distributions we care
about we actually have this more
sophisticated version
and uh the main result that we have is
that as long as you have this more
sophisticated uh uh counting algorithm
accounting or a call and your
distribution satisfies at all of its
covariances are bounded uh you get
basically this sort of parallel sampling
algorithm you get sampling algorithms
that run in polylog time uh but uh
slightly worse than Palm really many
processors quasi-polimating many
processors is what you need uh as long
as you know that all of your your
distributions uh have bounded
covariances or let's say they are
spectrally independent on it all
all right uh so this this condition of
being spectrally independent on their
exponentialities also has a name
fractional log concavity uh but we know
it for all of the distributions I
mentioned
uh yeah and uh also this weaker notion
of just the covenants is being bounded
by eyes you know
so uh so okay so so this main result
gives you a quasi RNC sampling algorithm
for elyrian tools it gives you a quasi
RNC sampling for dpps defined by a skew
symmetric Matrix
but actually we tried really hard to to
uh to remove this quasi
from all of these we were able to do
this in this paper for distributions
that satisfy something stronger than the
covariances being bounded distributions
that I call transport stable so I'll
Define transport stability later it's
some property of the distribution
but as long as you have this stronger
property you can change quasi quality to
poly and get like a fully kosher
parallel sample
so this holds for dpps defined via
symmetric psco matrices it holds for
spanning trees and so on okay
uh let me mention that this stronger
property it's not it's not that the case
that it doesn't hold for these we
actually conjecture that it holds for
all of these distributions we are just
not able to prove it for these
uh after this paper came out in some
ongoing work we tried to get rid of like
this condition and drop the Quasi in
these two cases too so it seems like we
can do it but this paper is not allowed
yet
uh all right so here is what transport
stability means
um so remember we were dealing with like
these exponential tilts so transport
stability says that as long as you
change the parameter of your tilt by a
small amount
your distributions change by a small
amount
okay and the way I measure the distance
between distributions is via Vassar side
distance so this is how much uh so if
you if you want to transport Mass
probability Mass from this distribution
to this distribution
on average how much in having distance
do you have to move
so that's that's water sign distance
and uh as long as it satisfies this
inequality that the transport distance
between your distributions is bounded by
some constant times the the L1 distance
between your tilt parameters
I'm going to call that transport
stability and this is a stronger notion
than uh than covariances and so on being
bounded I'll show you in the next few
slides as long as you have this you get
uh you get basically you get to drop the
Quasi
so for spanning trees and for dpps and
so on we can show that this holds with t
equals one one trivial fact is that this
holds for any distribution no matter
what with some worse constant sequence
order
just to show you like how this is
related to earlier stuff I showed you
semi-lock concavity was like a condition
on the covariance being bounded but you
can actually rewrite this in an
equivalent way
so the equivalent way is to say that the
means are are lip shits with respect to
the uh to the to the Tilt practice
that's because the covariance is somehow
the derivative of the mean
um so yeah so this is this is this is
the earlier semi-lock concavity
condition you just want the means of two
tilts in L2 to be bounded by c times the
the distance in L2 of the tail
parameters and you might say okay so
things here are L1 things here are L2
what's the relationship between them so
this condition is actually weaker than
the corresponding one for L1
so if you replace both of these twos by
one you get a stronger condition
and that that's obviously implied by
this so if you have two distributions
that are closed in one series line
distance their means are also closed in
L1
so that's why like this is like really
the strongest of all the conditions
so let me tell you where this transport
stability is coming from
um in the case of spanning trees for
example
um there is a uh there is a there's an
old theorem of federa and mihai uh that
works for spanning trees and dpps and so
on that tells you how to construct uh
some sort of a coupling between
conditionings of the spanning tree
distribution
so what does it say formally so you have
your spanning tree distribution
uniformly random spanning trees on a
graph pick your favorite Edge e so let's
say I don't know this Edge
there exists two random spanning trees
TNT Prime these are not independent
Rhino spanning trees they are dependent
fully dependent
such that when you look at them
individually the first one is uniformly
random conditioned on containing this
Edge the second one is uniformly random
condition that not containing this Edge
so they always like differ at least on
this Edge and they are as close as
possible in some sense so they have to
Define this Edge they must also differ
on somewhere else but that's all
so they always like differ on exactly
two edges as in this picture so these
two spot increase depend on exactly this
Edge and this Edge
showed that this sort of uh this sort of
this pair of random variables always
exists for spanning trees it also exists
in some other distributions in our paper
we show we show some similar statements
for distributions that I didn't talk
about so go look at the paper for those
but basically transport stability you
can get it from uh from statements like
this by gluing these couplings
essentially if you want to go from one
tilt to another tilt just change the
Tilt parameters one coordinate at a time
and use these couplings every time to to
construct like low transport distance uh
couplings between the machine
all right and I showed you transport
stability already implies Seminole okay
the actual conjecture that the same
thing the same uh actually Federer
behind statement holds in in uh in a
similar fashion for eulerian tours and
so on uh the difference is uh in in the
spanning tree case uh when you when when
you look at TNT Prime they are one swap
away so they are always like uh there
are like they defer on this Edge but the
other Edge must go the other way around
so like if if this one doesn't include
this Edge then this one includes the
other Edge
it's not necessarily a swap it's a flip
uh it should be
uh we also show for some distributions
that uh similar couplings hold for some
interesting distributions where you have
to use like longer uh longer distances
um but
so that's the connection that's how you
go beyond the Boolean hypercube that's
how you go to the continuous case now
let me show you the sampling algorithm
itself
so the sampling algorithm is as I
promised it's the same thing that
diffusion models use and also known as
stochastic localization in our community
uh
so here I've written the the whole
algorithm
um so just a quick note about the
algorithm so stochastic localization has
been a useful tool for analysis of
properties of distributions but it has
also been recently used algorithmically
by illali montenario and cell care so
this would be the second algorithmic use
of it
um the algorithm the way uh allow a
mountaineer yourself to use it uh is is
different from our use I'll tell you the
difference in one second but let me let
me first show you the algorithm
so uh so there is this uh there is this
uh random process that you are
constructing a little by little so there
is this tilt parameter W that you're
changing over time
you start with zero and the Tilt zero of
your distribution is the origin of
distribution
what you do in each step is you sample
from some noisy version of your
distribution so you add noise to get a
nice distribution a lock concave
distribution and then you sample from
this log concave distribution you get
some or some Vector in RN
and then you modify your tilts by
basically what you sampled you you add
what you sample to your tilt up to some
scaling
uh so maybe I don't know your samples
here and now you you tilt your
distribution this way
but again The Next Step you convolve
this with a gaussian uh to get a nice
smooth distribution you again sample
from it and then you you add whatever
you sample to your tilt and so on
uh as you can see like uh at least
pictorially this distribution is getting
more and more pointy uh it formally
always like converges it it with
probably one convergence to a
um to a point Mass uh as you as you do
this process uh uh for a large number of
steps
and we actually know uh the distribution
of this tilt parameter exactly at every
time step
um so uh uh so this is due to a
re-characterization of stochastic
localization by illalia montenari but
due to their characterization we know
exactly what the Tilt parameter at time
T is distributed as
um
so if you scale it appropriately you
divide it by time you divide you
multiply it by C it's just another noisy
version of your distribution so your
distribution comes involved with the
gaussian but the variance of discussion
is going to zero with time
so as T goes to Infinity you are getting
closer and closer to your distribution
so obviously like you know when T is
infinity this is this is good enough as
a sample probably
so one observation is you don't have to
go to Infinity
if you stop this process at roughly
login time uh the gaussian here will
have Infinity Norm bounded by a constant
let's say half
so there are n n independent questions
each are variance one over log n so the
maximum of them will be one half with
high probability
uh so then uh the sine of a plus one
minus Vector with something available
Infinity Norm bounded by half is the
same as the original plus one minus one
vector
so you can just like you can just round
the sample you have here just look at
the signs and the plus one minus one
vector you get is in TV distance close
to your uh to your distribution
yeah
all right so so one uh so okay so uh all
right so let me come back to this uh so
the uh so the way we are running
basically stochastic localization is a
faithful simulation of stochastic
localization up to how you do this step
um uh the version that allow you in
montenario and so okay use is instead of
doing sampling from a distribution like
this which is complicated in some cases
they just basically compute the mean of
this distribution and replace the entire
distribution by like a point mass at
them
so that introduces some approximation
errors but in their case like they can
tolerate it uh so that's why I'm saying
this is a different discretization
uh cool uh okay so
all right so one thing that I haven't
shown you so far is there is this
continuous distribution we know it's
locked concave but how do we actually
sample from it in parallel
right
uh so uh yeah going very fast
um okay so uh so this is actually an
open question in the continuous sampling
community so you have a continuous
distribution it's well conditioned lock
concave
how many how many times you have to
query let's say the density of your
function or its gradients or it's like
low order derivatives before you can
output a sample
so this is the minimal number that you
need the minimal number of these queries
that you need is open
uh uh so so you know uh you could
possibly you could feasibly uh have have
an algorithm that only queries poly
login menu such things and then you
don't even need to care about like
parallelization it's just you know
uh but so far we don't know of any
algorithms like this in fact there are
some people who are trying to prove
impossibility of this
fortunately though uh parallel uh
sampling in poly login time is not open
uh so there is this work of Shannon Lee
that we use as a black box that gives
you uh samples uh but let me let me tell
you like the idea that goes behind these
sorts of algorithms at least
uh there is also like a uh in our
ongoing work we we uh we pack we use
basically the same parallelization idea
to a different sampling algorithm
what goes in paralyzing like sampling
algorithms that you might be familiar
with is
you always have some sort of a
stochastic differential equation that
you have discretized here I've written
back to this critization of uh uh launch
band Dynamics
so what does it say it's like a noisy
version of gradient descent you you move
from it a point x t to a point x t plus
DT by just moving a little bit in the
direction of the gradient of your log
density so that's similar to gradient
descent but you also add noise
all right so this is very sequential
because you know you have to go from XT
to X plus uh T to x t plus BT and then
to XT plus 2 DT and so on but there is
this general idea you can use called
Picard iterations to parallelize all
sorts of algorithms like this the idea
is uh
think of basically like uh think tearing
this like sequential like thing into a
fixed Point problem and then iterate
uh so what do I mean by that so imagine
you have a a trajectory of these points
initially like started at a random guess
or something like some arbitrary yes
what I can do is I can uh I can compute
the gradients of log density at my
current trajectory and use those uh to
get a new trajectory like this
so x t i minus 1 is my trajectory at
iteration I minus one I compute all of
these things in parallel and then I just
like compute the prefix sums of them to
get a new trajectory xti
so this is this is a an operation that
Maps a trajectory to a trajectory it's
called Picard iteration
and this thing you can actually just
iterate poly lock times and it'll
converge to the fixed point of this
operation which would be a solution of
this
so Shannon Lee basically use a similar
idea but to a different algorithm it's
not the it's not the launch band
Dynamics but in our ongoing work we
should not even for launch run Dynamics
basically
cool uh all right
so uh so yeah so so that's that's
basically the gist of the algorithm now
you can just piece it together with the
previous framework to get your
algorithms uh now let me go back to uh
transport stability and tell you why we
get we got the two different results
quasi with the Quasi and without the
Quasi
so the reason is very subtle but this is
the last slide
uh so uh okay so the the point is uh
this continuous sampling algorithms they
come with approximate sampling
guarantees so the the point they said
they produce for you is not a it's it's
never a true sample from your
distribution it's always approximately
uh from your distribution so uh really
like the devil is in the details so what
kind of approximation guarantee do you
have so in the work of Shannon Lee the
the approximation guarantee they have is
that you get some point that is uh you
get a sample from a distribution that's
in Bossier sign distance close to your
distribution
and uh because these uh these uh W's
that you sample are tilts of future
steps you need you need to tolerate like
a change uh in the in the sales
parameter
and so transport stability is is able to
tolerate those kinds of errors so
basically the if you know that uh in in
some step your distributions are have
Epsilon Vassar Stein error uh every
iteration from that point on that
Epsilon gets multiplied by a c
if you know C is transport
okay so for spanning trees and so on uh
every step your error gets multiplied by
a constant but you only have log n of
those steps
so you're so the errors in the beginning
get multiplied by only a polynomial
Factor so it's enough to start with an
inverse formulas smaller
in general for General distributions you
can only say that the errors get
multiplied by o of n every step
and so after login steps they get
multiplied by n to the log n so that's
why you need to start with an inverse
quasi polynomial there
so that's that's all there is to that
difference
and basically uh
in our ongoing work the way we get
around this issue is by giving parallel
Samplers that don't give you Buster sign
accuracy but give you TV distance
accuracy
so TV distance accuracy doesn't have
this problem that it blows up over time
cool uh so let me conclude so I showed
you some algorithms for some some way of
using stochastic localization to get
parallel sampling algorithms there are
some open problems here so planar
perfect matchings is the case that we
didn't solve um
but more generally these are wide open
questions as far as I know the answer to
them should be yes
so I use some assumptions on the
distribution like uh uh you know I don't
know spectral Independence or semi-lock
concavity and so on uh but what is the
complexity of for arbitrary
distributions of sampling given Oracle
access to the Laplace transform or
Oracle access to the sub Cube accounting
thing
if you're interested I can even give you
like candid algorithms that I think
should work in parallel here but we we
just we're just not able to analyze
thank you
questions for Nemo
um
you get a TV error what's what's the
difference
yeah so it's a one
there are two issues okay so uh since
you mentioned uh the the workup uh
allowing in their work they study
sampling from the Sheraton Tech Patrick
model if you know what that is
so the issue uh the issue is uh
and and they get a worse guarantee for
sound for for they get a worse than TV
distance guarantee then uh uh for for
their sampling algorithm so there are
there is a fundamental reason they can't
get uh TV license guarantee the reason
is we had like this like clean given
counting Oracles in their Works they
have they only have approximate counting
on
so so essentially like the continuous
distribution like even if you wanted to
like plug in plug that distribution into
our framework you would only have access
to let's say approximate PDFs of those
continuous distributions
uh so so with those approximate accesses
uh you you just don't get uh you can
never get like rid of the WhatsApp sign
instance
um another reason why Surfside distance
shows up is because they are using like
a different discretization but in their
case because they have together sign
distance error it's like
yes
um
this is actually previous work oh and
the other work
uh doing uh this thing or the other uh
other
s
uh
so this is uh okay
um this one
um
so this is okay so so okay so so this is
like a mathematical process this is not
formally an algorithm you have to like
plug in something for here together
but this mathematical process here they
they just use it in in some analysis as
someone analysis technique and they show
that like the if you do this like
accurately at every step the
distribution of WT you get is something
like this
um this is a mathematical statement
uh say what was the question again
because you said that the first part
basically converges your distribution to
it with point that it's great yes so
that's that's actually easy to see once
you know this characterization so if you
give me like uh if you give me like a
distribution if you give me a w that's
distributed like this for a very very
large team
uh you put T times that as your external
appeal so then it's converging to
something that's like infinitely large
and so like it's very easy to see that
that that just like puts the
Empire mass of your distribution on
whatever was your sample from here
so so okay so you can make this album a
little bit more complicated by not just
rounding like the not just rounding the
Tilt parameter but actually like
Computing what this distribution is for
a large D and then looking at what point
Mass it's close to and then taking that
sample but these are like formally of
course
yeah
that's the the algorithm relies on
Sample from a convolution
yes do we have a good understanding on
like what kind of distributions actually
I use these examples after the world
with Russia a lot of distributions I
think are in the continuous
distribution if one since then it's
actually very difficult to sample yes
that's a that's a good point
so if you start with a
distribution you have to have some sort
of accounting Oracle corresponding to
like integrating your function under
recognition measure which is pretty hard
to do
but uh yeah I don't have a good answer
except for like the distributions here
um also like yeah in general uh in the
discrete case uh many times you have not
just determinants based counting but you
have other accounting algorithms that
are let's say not based on Markov chains
so like deterministic counting
algorithms such as the ones given by
based on the barbadox method and so on
so all of those would give you actually
paralyzable counting algorithms the
differences they are approximate
of that
up to that small difference for all of
those convolving with gaussians is also
that
we explained
the question
here is the hard case uh let's say your
entire graph is just a giant cycle
so this has two perfect matchings the
odd edges and the evanges so then your
distribution is like half half on two
opposite ends of the hypercube
then you can easily see that if you put
like gaussians on top of these
the distance of these two points is very
large so you have to put very wide
questions for them to reach each other
and yeah that's that's kind of the
intuition like uh for for spanning trees
things are actually close to each other
we know from combinatorics that we can
move in the space of spanning trees by
just just doing local changes and that's
that's basically the intuition of why
putting small versions on top of sun
trees uh gives you a lot of concave
description
zero
ah W zero zero this one or no the next
level
it's actually okay so that's it that's a
good question uh you actually have to
start this from somewhere close to the
mode of your distribution but the mode
is easy to find using gradients
so you just cut start from like the
constant trajectory in here
on the previous slide
stochastic
cosmetically this looks a lot like the
polarization step in fractions
is there is that just a circus level
thing or
I just don't know
to me it looks yeah coincidence but yeah
[Music]
many different uh
uh oh yeah what I meant was uh
yeah so okay so in the Spanish tree case
uh this is this is what we have so uh in
the hype like the translator to the
hydrogative language uh you can you can
have two vectors X and Y two random
mixer vectors X and Y plus one minus one
yeah such that x minus y is always so
you fix your favorite coordinate I
it's a big sign
so you can make sure that this is always
e i minus E J for some J
and that's equivalent to what I wrote
um in the in the eulerian tour case
what you need is not not this it could
also be the case that x minus y is so
basically you know in area to our case
you have to put a plus here
so it would be like either like uh you
saw up at minus two plus or a plus
so that's yeah so that's what we find
the extra shoot holes providers we can't
prove it but we can prove similar
statements for more complicated
distributions there are some
distributions for which you can put this
this difference is
again
[Applause]
we'll return in 30 minutes